the ruling class
is really really
weird it's getting really bizarre really
out there
okay and
at the international level
the level of these groups that transcend
nations like the united nations
one of their obsessions is climate
change because climate change used to be
global cooling there was global warming
then it was climate change now i guess
they call it climate crisis or climate
catastrophe it is this apocalyptic
prediction
that tells us the end of the world is
imminent unless we give them all the
money and all the power
and so we've got it got to just go along
with it
they are now playing at the u.n
four world leaders
a really scientific erudite serious
video
of a dinosaur lecturing everybody about
extinction
listen up people
i know a thing or two about extinction
and let me tell you
and you kind of think this would be
obvious
going extinct is a bad thing
and driving yourselves extinct
in 70 million years that's the most
ridiculous thing i've ever heard at
least we had an asteroid
what's your excuse
you're headed for a climate disaster and
yet every year governments spend
hundreds of billions of public funds on
fossil fuel subsidies
imagine if we had spent hundreds of
billions per year subsidizing giant
meteors that's what you're doing right
now
think of all the other things you could
do with that money
around the world people are living in
poverty
don't you think helping them would make
more sense than i don't know paying for
the demise of your entire species
let me be real for a second
you've got a huge opportunity right now
as you rebuild your economies and bounce
back from this pandemic this is
humanity's big chance
three
really important aspects here to the
dinosaur lecturing the world leaders
a sentence i never thought i would utter
first of all he goes back to this
ridicul the dinosaur does he goes back
to this ridiculous talking point that
you hear a lot from the environmentalist
lunatics and he says you're subsidizing
fossil fuels you
oh my your governments your taxpayer
dollars are subsidizing ritual uncle
penny bags at the oil company
what does that mean that obviously isn't
true so what is it what does he mean by
that
we're just giving direct payments to
the oil tycoons that's what's going on
why are we doing why would we do that
why would taxpayers and why would the
government just even from a political
optics standpoint why would they
subsidize the oil companies
because they are paying for poor people
to heat their homes among other things
what do you think oil subsidies means
we're paying the government is paying
oil companies and buying oil one because
it has its own needs for oil but two
is part of a welfare program for poor
people to heat their homes so is your is
your argument no the poor people should
freeze that way we won't the sun monster
won't be angry and we can appease the
great sun god and then he won't destroy
the world in 18 months or 12 years or
whatever they keep changing the number
no i don't think that
i am more interested in helping the poor
people heat their homes in the winter
helping
widows and orphans stay warm in the
winter
than i am in protecting a rock
or or the delta smelt or even the polar
bears who are doing just fine by the way
that's the first part that's so
ridiculous
the second part
that is so ridiculous is that he's he's
already by the end the dinosaur is
already taking it beyond climate change
beyond this one issue of he goes this is
an opportunity
this pandemic it's an opportunity for a
would you say a great reset i don't know
for a way to transform the economy to
transform it's a great opportunity the
third thing that is really important
about this
is that it's a video of a dinosaur
lecturing world leaders
the not a scientist
not a not an expert
a cartoon dinosaur because
these are not serious people this is not
a serious
issue this is a power grab based on
fear-mongering
and bread and circuses and fantasy
the
environmentalists are pushing for this
imminent destruction of the world or
pushing for massive global action the
upending of societies to stop the end of
the world they are not serious people
did you like that clip
i i liked that clip as well i liked that
you liked it if you want to get these
notifications you've got to ring the
bell and subscribe you still probably
won't get notifications because some
people around here don't
particularly care for our show
youtube
but you can also subscribe at apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
click that button maybe leave a
five-star review we'll see you next time
[Music]